I welcome to Hannity on this busy
breaking news night we begin with the
Fox News Alert we have big breaking news
on multiple fronts now Senator Lindsey
Graham will be here with a huge
announcement tonight that he is planning
to introduce a motion in the United
States Senate to condemn the so called
impeachment inquiry in the house it is
corrupted as unconstitutional I have a
very special message for senator Mitt
Romney tonight you're not going to want
to miss first this is very important
we're going to break down tonight in
detail something corrupt and dangerous
to this Democratic Republic that we love
we will expose on this program the
Democrats top secret their Soviet style
and Pietschmann coup attempt and how it
is an unprecedented unconstitutional
attempt to nullify the will of the
American people the whole process is
more corrupt lacking all due process all
constitutionality and constitutional
protections it is based on utter and
complete nonsense zero violation of any
law by the president all the president
is really guilty of his faithfully
executing the laws of this land and
fulfilling his constitutional duty we
will explain and explore this partisan
Democrats detached from any objective
truth to be a Democrat you can't believe
in truth reason common sense this is now
a lawless mob now noting that we are
witness witnesses driven by facts logic
law constitutionality no a psychotic
rage and hatred at all things Trump even
the mention of his name these Democrats
their allies and the media mob they are
triggered by the mere sound of President
Trump's name they are set off and
triggered by the sight of a red Maggie
hat on a sixteen-year-old innocent kid
what we're living through and witnessing
is a level of madness as a country and
we better stop or we're not going to
have a country and yes it's that serious
now in their latest effort to take this
president down the Cowardly the corrupt
Adam Schiff is holding secret hearings
meetings that result in secret
transcripts all hidden from the American
people the Trump administration the
president's lawyers this has never
happened ever in any previous
impeachment proceeding now forget any
and all constitutional due process is
beyond the kangaroo court I can't even
believe it's happening in America an
attempted political coup where you have
the corrupt the cowardly the shifty
shift making all the rules as he goes
new rules rules that were never used in
the past Adam Schiff is a habitual liar
we know that and as white House Counsel
Pat's Apollonia asserted in a brutal
takedown it is quote designed and
implemented implemented the inquiry in a
manner that violates fundamental
fairness constitutionality in a
constitutionally mandated process they
have denied the president the right to
cross-examine witnesses to call
witnesses to receive transcripts of
testimony to have access to evidence to
have counsel present and many other
basic rights guaranteed to all Americans
guaranteed to Nixon and guaranteed to
Bill Clinton all of this violates the
Constitution and the rule of law and
every pass precedent now keep in mind in
the 90s Newt Gingrich who will join us
tonight modeled the impeachment
proceeding against Bill Clinton after
the way the Democrats did it against
Richard Nixon totally the same way there
was a full vote in the house that
authorized the proceeding the scope was
defined rules and procedures were
publicly established we got to see it
Koel subpoena power granted to both
parties subpoenas were subject to a vote
of the full committee the president's
counsel could attend all hearings and
all depositions the president's counsel
and the right to present evidence object
to any evidence admitted cross-examine
witnesses and recommend witnesses now
those were basic rights afforded to Bill
Clinton and Richard Nixon not President
Trump you have the lying the cowardly
the corrupt shift well he is something
very different in mine and at this hour
the Democrats illegitimate inquiry is
becoming even more secretive believe
this or not breaking tonight Democrats
are literally blocking house
Republicans from even having a copy a
copy of the transcripts of the secret
hearings they don't want you to watch
Republicans want to simply read a
transcript they have to have a
Democratic minder a staffer babysit them
we're talking about hearings that should
be held in public to start with hearings
that my sources by the way and telling
me is blowing up in the corrupt shifts
face and Democrats face there's only a
few months ago that they demanded
remember the full the unredacted Muller
report it all needs to be publicly
available for all to see
oh that's now changed everything now is
in secret take a look we don't need
anymore summaries we don't anymore
eat anymore spin we just need to see the
words the report we need to see the work
of the special counsel period here's
what's important is that the public sees
the report contemporaneously with the
president he should not be allowed to
edit you should not be allowed to
restrict or sanitize the Mullah report
should indeed be made public we need to
see every bit of these underlying
documents and the full mahler report we
need every word of it to be a
functioning democracy a functioning
democracy
okay now Democrats won't even hold the
public vote nothing is transparent as
transparent no transcript no hearing no
nothing no rights for the president no
rights for Republicans and no outrage
from the media mob over the secrecy and
how corrupt this impeachment coup
attempt really is none whatsoever
they are nothing the mob and the media
but an extension of the Democratic Party
so what is the Cowardly corrupt Adam
Schiff hiding spoiler alert he's hiding
a lot sources telling me many sources
that the corrupt shift star witnesses
they're not cooperating with his phony
witch hunt and his narrative one person
brought in after another debunking the
big lie about Donald Trump withholding
funds to Ukraine Democrats don't want
these transcripts to become public
because it will destroy this phony
corrupt narrative
instead they want to control all the
information so they can hoe selectively
leaked that one sentence that they think
helps them editorialize testimony to win
public support against the president now
do you see what is going on here it is a
con job it is run by the biggest snake
in the Washington swamp and that says a
lot that's another big reason for the
secrecy why well the cowardly corrupt
Adam Schiff he doesn't want to be
exposed he is a fact witness in this
case in his own inquiry he has no
business this is a total conflict of
interest remember his office was in
contact with the non whistleblower
whistleblower the hearsay whistleblower
before they ever filed the complaint
that sparked the and entire inquiry ship
is on tape lying about that contact in
these seedy communications now chef
doesn't want this individual to testify
now why would that be because then the
so called non whistleblower would be
forced to answer questions about the
whistleblowers relationship with shifts
office like I have a few questions
when did you start communicating with
chefs office did shifts office advise
you to get an attorney did that attorney
write any portion of the complaint the
chief's office advised you to contact
the IG how did you get your third-party
hearsay information and let's all
remember one important fact this is a
secret investigation over a public
transcript the irony is we don't need a
hearsay non whistleblower whistleblower
Trump wants to they're surprised in
chagrin release the entire transcript
look at your screen no quid pro quo
whatsoever now where is the crime here
where the favor that's where I need a
favor
has nothing to do with creepy crazy
sleepy Uncle Joe Biden and nothing to do
with the 2020 elections Biden was
mentioned in passing later in the phone
call but if you look at the paragraphs
and that is supposedly to be so
pertinent the president is clearly
referring to Ukrainian election and
appearance in the 2016 election look at
what political out
line January 11 2017 they're not members
of the vast right-wing conspiracy you
come in the country Ukraine tried their
best to get Hillary Clinton elected
Ukrainian government officials tried to
help Hillary Clinton and undermine Trump
by publicly questioning his fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aide in
corruption and suggest that they were
investigating the matter only to back
away after the election and they helped
Clinton's allies research damaging
information on Trump and his advisers
this gets even better because the report
goes on to detail a clear example of yes
Ukrainian DNC collusion and Ukrainian
American operative who was consulting
for the Democratic National Committee
met with top officials in the Ukrainian
Embassy in Washington in an effort to
expose ties between Trump Trump campaign
aide Paul Manafort and Russia according
to people with direct knowledge of the
situation hang on a second I just we
just spent what three years the media
mob Democrats breathlessly reporting
screaming about election interference
and this is a big deal and we can't have
this in the country
okay then they should all be thanking
president Trump for getting to the
bottom of the DNC colluding with Ukraine
to interfere in the 2016 elections to
help Hillary by the way it's important
to remember one more thing about the
president's phone call with Ukraine and
the president said I'd like you to do us
a favor okay well that's a favor okay
there were no strings attached zero quid
pro quo doesn't exist because during the
call the government of Ukraine had no
idea the US had temporarily delayed aid
and they still got the eight plus the
aid was never attached to anything
nothing and that's clear in the
transcript especially related as sleepy
creepy Uncle Joe
especially related to the 2020 election
and let's be clear the term do us a
favor well we all have go-to phrases you
know I'll say you know a lot the
president uses them all the time kind of
a verbal aside like
proved my point take a look she just did
me a beautiful favor keeping it a
beautiful Sikorsky plant open in the
great state of Pennsylvania I'm talking
to your ambassador Jared was there
Jason Greenblatt was there I said fellas
do me a favor you're doing us a favor
because it's a great job you do they
called and they say could you possibly
make it another day and we delay the
doings so we did them a favor but
they're doing us a favor but they're
buying a lot of agricultural product
Edison would you do me a favor the
remains of these great fallen heroes can
we do something he agreed to it
immediately like big league for the
president so to recap the term do me a
favor that's the phrase the president
uses we've identified hundreds of times
no conditions whatsoever you can look at
the transcript of the phone call no quid
pro quo look at the transcript no hi
Craig no misdemeanor no bribery no
treason but that doesn't matter to the
left and their friends and the mob they
are obsessed with impeaching this
president ever since you the American
people shocked the world in November
2016 and I hope you shocked the world
again in 2020 they started with the word
impeachment two days after election day
by the way the nine-month investigation
into Trump Russia collusion empty the
FBI investigation nothing house Intel
investigation no collusion bipartisan
said an investigation 22-month
Muller witch-hunt no collusion
whatsoever now we have the secret Soviet
style attempted impeachment coup it's
just the latest pathetic attempt by
people that never accepted the results
of the 2016 election and want to
influence the next election and
meanwhile there is evidence of a quid
pro quo right in plain sight has nothing
to do with President Trump everything to
do with sleepy creepy crazy joe 303 300
and his son by the way it's not a kid
he's 49 years old 2015 14 Biden put in
charge of the Obama administration's
Ukraine policy his son hunter thereafter
got a lucrative millions of dollars
barista Holdings contract to be on the
which is a massive Ukrainian oil gas and
energy company owned by a Ukrainian
oligarch owner was being paid millions
of dollars no experience in Ukraine
energy oil gas none Maurice Moe wasn't
paying for his experience now could you
imagine if this was Vice President Trump
and hunter was Don jr. what do you think
the media outrage would be it would lead
every news cycle forever but once again
well there you have the left has nothing
to do with truth logic basic common
sense of fairness instead they can't
help they want to take down this
president that they hate because they're
terrified guess what
the ultimate revenge if they impeach
them is going to be you deciding to
reelect him their fears well are
warranted let's look at the brand new
Zogby poll president beats all of his
Democratic rivals in a head-to-head
matchup he except for Elizabeth Warren
their tie and I'm not sure that's gonna
be the case Moody's forecasting a
whopping three hundred and fifty one
electoral vote win for Trump good news
won't mean anything if the Democrats are
able to weaponize the impeachment
process this is for this country and all
hands on deck moment because without due
process in total secrecy and Democrats
removing a sitting president from office
or attempting this is not how this great
Republic operates this is corruption at
its worst it is constitutionally lacking
in all validity and I don't care if
you're a liberal conservative Democrat
Republican if you care about truth and
justice and due process you will speak
out about this corruption and abuse of
power